Das war's für heute.
auch nicht gemountet. Ansonsten komme ich auch auf deutlich mehr. Allein die ZFS-Kiste,
die hinter mir steht halt 20TB. Auch das ist die, wo ich seit ich immer ja sage, die kommt
weg. Aber sie ist immer noch da. Ja, zu diesen Geschichten mit Windows, C-Doppelpunkt,
C-Doppelpunkt, warum das so heißt, ich habe keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt. Eigentlich habe
ich jetzt gehofft, der Chat sagt, ja ne, warum ist das so? Und dann kann ich sagen, weil
ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe nämlich keine Ahnung, warum das so ist. Ich finde es nur
unglaublich unsinnig, die Windows-Bezeichnung. Ich meine, das ist C-Doppelpunkt für die
Festplatte. Das kann ich mir noch erklären, weil A und B das Kettenlaufwerk waren. Aber
warum man überhaupt auf diese Bezeichnung kommt? Ich muss sagen, da kommt mir die Unix-Geschichte
mit Slash als Hut deutlich sinnvoller vor. Moment, warum? Moment Leute. Warum um alles
in der Welt ist hier Best of Vivaldi offen? Es ist der Vivaldi Browser, aber warum? Ah,
was? Exzellent Musik. Exquisite. Ah, Five Head Wine, Leute. So, jetzt erstmal hier 25-jähriger
schottischer Premium-Bilski aufmachen. Ah, yes, exzellent. Muss ich ein paar Szenen
Musik dazu. Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das auffahrt, ehrlich gesagt. WTF Bait, natürlich
Bait, das ist Orangensaft, der hier steht. Als hätte ich 25-jährigen schottischen Whisky
da. Da könnte man, ja, das war kein Ding. Die sind gar nicht, also je nachdem was, ist
es gar nicht so teuer. Also für 20, 30 Euro gibt es ja schon ganz gutes Zeug. Nicht, dass
ich jetzt irgendwie der exzellent Whisky-Experte wäre oder so. Ok, erstmal Don't Run. Ich
habe heute, deswegen bin ich auf die Idee gekommen, wir müssen uns das Ganze mal angucken. Ich
habe heute, war ich glaube bei Hacker News, ist es bei Hacker News irgendwo, habe ich
gelesen, dass irgendwie Solos 2.1 oder so rausgekommen ist. Das ist eine Linux-Distribution,
von der habe ich ab und zu schon mal was gehört, aber hatte nie das großartige, oder ne, ist
schon ein paar Tage her. Aber egal, ich habe es heute irgendwo gelesen. Nie das großartige
Bedürfnis. Seit wann nutzt du Vivaldi? Seit er rausgekommen ist eigentlich. Aber ich benutze
alle möglichen Browser. Guck mal, ich meine wir haben Vivaldi, Chromium, Chrome, Edge,
Internet Explorer und Edge neu. Und Firefox. Wir haben alles drauf. Das einzige was uns
noch fehlt ist Opera, aber den sehe ich kein Content zu installieren. Gut, ich habe heute
eine Review gelesen oder so eine Übersicht. Ich glaube bei Hacker News war es. Ich muss
die Musik enttegnen. Reisermachen. Genau und zwar, die haben einen eigenen Desktop entwickelt.
Die haben nämlich einen Batschi-Desktop. Warum auch immer ist noch ein extra Desktop
unter Linux? Keine Ahnung, weil das halt exzellent ist. Keine Ahnung. Zumindest habe ich mir
gedacht, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an. Es sieht für mich aus ein bisschen wie eine
Gnome Shell, aber ich glaube ist es nicht. Der ist noch luxuriierer, steht da. Ah doch,
Gnome. Also ich habe keine Ahnung ob das eine Gnome Shell ist oder ob das nur etwas ist
was auf GTK basiert. Keine Ahnung. Deswegen, das probieren wir aus. Ansonsten haben die
noch ähnliche Sachen zur Auswahl wie, ähm, Dings, na wie heißt es, Ubuntu Dings hier,
Mint, ähm, ähnliche Sachen. Die haben hier Mate, haben die zur Auswahl noch, die haben
hier eine Gnome Variante, die haben Plasma. Plasma ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine KDE Geschichte
oder so. Plasma klingt irgendwie nach KDE, ja. Also ich habe alles mögliche, aber hier
diese Batschi Variante ist wohl das von denen entwickelte. Übrigens wir haben ein paar
neue Emotes, leider ist mein Vorschau so kaputt, dass ich sie mir nicht anzeigen lassen kann.
Ich habe ein paar neue Emotes reingemacht, allerdings keine Sub Emotes, sondern äh, äh,
FFZ Emotes oder Better Twitch TV Emotes habe ich ein paar reingemacht. Ein paar neue. Zum
Beispiel Pepo Clap und ein paar andere. Ich weiß gar nicht, ihr könnt ja mal ausprobieren,
ich weiß gar nicht was ich alles reingemacht habe, 5-6 Stück nur. Weil ich habe gesehen,
dass man bei Better Twitch TV jetzt anstatt 25 irgendwie auf einmal 80 Emotes oder so haben
kann. Und ich habe jetzt einfach random ein paar Emotes reingeklickt, aber ich weiß nicht
was mit Better Twitch TV los ist, wahrscheinlich wollen sie das mehr Leute 5 Euro im Monat
bezahlen. Für Better Twitch TV Premium. Genau Trigger ist auch dabei. Pepega ist schon lange
dabei, das ist nichts Neues. Die, der, der, der Livestream. Habt ihr eigentlich schon?
Leute, wer von euch verwendet FFZ? Ich muss euch nämlich noch was zeigen. Ich muss euch
mal was zeigen. Wir machen das jetzt, wir machen das jetzt mal im Chrome. Ich muss euch
nämlich was zeigen. FFZ hat, also beziehungsweise was zeigen und was fragen, die dies verwenden.
Erweiterung hinzufügen, alles gut. Ok, weil Twitch Roblox, FFZ hat jetzt, naja ich stimme
zu, machen wir hier jetzt mal dicht. FFZ hat jetzt ein neues, Moment, wo ist es denn? FFZ
hat ein neues Feature, nämlich, hier, guckt mal. Ah, man sieht sich. FFZ hat jetzt hier
unten so ein Equalizer Ding oder Kompressor. Das ist richtig nice. Jetzt ist halt ein bisschen
kaputt. Das hat so ein Equalizer Feature. Das ist hyper, hyper nice. Hier, das da meine
ich. Das bringt richtig was. Also, für alle, die es nicht haben, kann ich das nur empfehlen,
mal auszuprobieren. Weil es ist auf Twitch, jeder Streamer hat irgendwie ein bisschen
andere Audio-Settings. Und ich finde, die haben ein ziemlich gutes Preset aus Hörbarkeit
von Streamer-Commentary und gleichzeitig In-Game-Sound, auch wenn das Streamer und Hintergrundmusik,
das haben die echt gut gemacht. FFZ, Franker, Faces, sie. Franker sie, Franker sie, Franker
sie. Yeah, und das ist das beste, beste FFZ. Wenn wir gerade dabei sind, können wir auch
mal gucken, was ich für neue Immodes gemacht habe. Die sieht man dann hier schön an. Und
wir haben die huge loading, vielleicht backt es jetzt da mit rum. Die modes funktionieren
richtig gut. Weiß nicht warum es jetzt nicht funktioniert. Eigentlich ist das überhaupt
kein Problem. Kann es sein, dass der emote server gerade irgendwie down ist von dem?
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen, dass das nicht lädt. Lustig. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass
es geht, dass es nicht lädt. Bei mir läuft es, ja. Okay, ich weiß nicht was die gerade
für Schmerzen haben, aber anscheinend ist es gerade ein bisschen kaputt. Ah, Monka S.
Okay, das andere lädt nicht. Super, es ist gerade voll kaputt. Aber wie gesagt, das kann
ich jedem nur empfehlen und eine Sache müsst ihr machen, wenn ihr ffz installiert habt,
nämlich ihr müsst gif-emotes einschalten, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen jetzt nicht
drin sind. Ah, das ist weil ich die better twitch tv-emotes in mir installiert habe.
Genau, addons, ich muss erst den Kram aktivieren. Ja, kann man den Kram vergrößern.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal better twitch tv-emotes aktivieren. Und jetzt funktioniert das nämlich
auch. Und da muss man unbedingt sagen gif-animierte-emotes, sonst funktioniert es nicht. Wenn man jetzt
nämlich reloadet, dann funktioniert nämlich der Kram auch. Wenn ich jetzt nach hier Korgas,
dann geht auch, naja gut, ich kann jetzt nicht. Ach, wahrscheinlich kann ich nicht laden,
weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin. Naja, bestes bestes emote, weiß gar nicht, wie wir da drauf
gekommen sind. Sag mal, kann die Hintergrundmusik sich mal überlegen, wie laut sie sein möchte.
Gut, aber zurück zu dem eigentlich, was wir machen wollen, nämlich solo solidox ausprobieren.
Ähm, laden wir die ganzen Krampel mal runter. Excellent download, yes. Genau, den haha-Typ
habe ich auch noch hier drin. Aber am besten ist pepo clap, Leute, ihr müsst mal alle ausprobieren.
Pepo clap, bestes neues emote. Pepo clap. Äh, ich glaube, ich habe jede Menge im Chat
übersehen fällt mir gerade ein. Ähm, wobei nö, wenn ich so durchscrolle. Oh, turids,
twitch prime, huge sub. Kann das sein, dass ich keinen Subscriber-Sound habe? Oder ist
mein Subscriber-Sound kaputt? Nee, aber ohne Mist. Probieren wir mal aus. Ich mache mal
einen Test-Sound. Streamlabs, äh, Streamlabs, nicht Steamlabs. Warum ist auf jedem Werbebild
von Twitch Pokimane eigentlich drauf? Ich meine, außer dass es gut ausschaut, finde
ich die Streamlabs, meine persönliche Meinung, nicht sonderlich spannend. So, wir machen
jetzt mal ein Alert. Nee, funktioniert. Funktioniert. Äh, kurze Frage, was ist dein favorite
Xbox? Ähm, Manjaro mit i3-WM. Gd, kono, dankeschön. Pepo clap, huge sub. Dankeschön. So, ne,
download, download nach. Hast du einen extra Rechner zum Streamen? Also halbe halbe. Also,
ich streame, ich streame hier schon von meinem eigentlichen Rechner, wo ich auch alle Zeug
drauf spiele, Zeug ausprobiere. Aber ich hab noch einen zweiten Rechner zum Vorschau für
den Chat und ähm, für Emotes und solche Zeug. Ich hab mir so ein Dashboard gebastelt, wo
man, ähm, Emotes und Sounds abspielen kann. Und das bediene ich überm Browser auf dem
zweiten Bildschirm. Ok, Download fertig, dann gucken wir jetzt mal, dass wir eine VM anlegen,
allerdings eine VM auf, auf diesem, auf der, auf der zweiten SSD. Mal probieren wir das
ganze mal aus. BSP-WM, i3-WM. Warum? Warum? Hab letztens in einem Video drüber gesehen,
also, war jetzt nichts dabei, wo ich gesagt hätte, oh ja, das muss unbedingt, äh, brauch
ich das. Was ist Asianux? Nie gehört. Oracle-E-Kick. So, und das machen wir jetzt nicht da, sondern
da. Äh, äh, Solus. Next. Ähm, drei CPUs sollte reichen. 4G RAM, NAT, Next, Next,
Next. Äh, 80. Haben genug. Single File. Hast du auch mal ein Interesse in den FreeBSD
oder andere Äußer aus der BSD-Familie? Äh, ja, können wir machen, aber ich muss sagen,
BSD hab ich ganz wenig Ahnung von. Das einzige von BSD, was ich weiß, ist, dass die wohl
eine große globale Config-Datei haben. Das war's. Das einzige, wo ich bisher Live-Kontakt
mit BSD hatte, ist FreeNAS und OpenSense. Das ist automatische Teilnehmer. Ok, wir schmeißen
das erste Mal den Printer raus. Den brauchen wir nämlich garantiert nicht. Erst lassen
wir da. Finish. So, legen wir das Viso rein und gucken wir uns das Ganze an. Downloads,
Solus, Bucci. Übrigens, äh, Twitch-Chat. Wir haben uns ja schon so ein paar Inder-Scam-Videos
angeguckt auf YouTube und da habt ihr mich immer gefragt, ob ich Kid Boga kenne auf Twitch
und ich hab immer gesagt, sagt mir nix, also kenn den Channel, hab ich nie geguckt. Ich
hab letztens mal geguckt, der Typ ist richtig gut. Der ist eigentlich viel zu überqualifiziert
für Twitch. Der könnte damit irgendwo eine komplett eigene Sendung machen. Der ist richtig
gut. Der hat's drauf, was Inder-Scam-Verarschen angeht. Der ist huge. Vor allem, wie kreativ
der ist, was ihm zwischendurch einfällt, während er mit dem telefoniert. Also der ist wirklich
gut. Ich hab letztens mal angemacht, hab ich gar nicht mit gerechnet und richtig gut.
Automatic Boot. Mal gucken, wohin's bootet. Best of auf YouTube. Ja, ich hab ein bisschen
den Stream dann noch nachgeguckt. Ähm, ja, das mit Edmar kenn ich mit der Oma. Natürlich
nicht komplett, ja. Und vor allem, dass er dann auch irgendwann noch, ähm, wie heißen
sie Alex und Adam und Alex? Die zwei Inder. Dass er die dann noch öfters auch schon reingekriegt
hat. Übels nice. Okay, es fühlt sich übelst schnell an, obwohl es eine Live-CD ist. Aber
man muss ja sagen, es ist eine Live-CD von Platte. Reinstalliert man das denn? Gimm'
it, ha? Schauen wir mal, ob die in der Lage sind, vor allem, Tools zu installieren. Bis
die das hingekriegt haben, stretchen wir das Ganze, dass wir hier die richtige Kacknoop-Installer-Experience
haben. Englisch, United States. So, brauchen wir das. Wo hab ich mein Kokona? Kokona, wo
ist mein Kokona? Ah ja, da, passend. Kokona-Language. So. Where are you? Find my location. Okay,
das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, ob das funktioniert. Finde nur den Stimmverzerrer ein wenig. Das
braucht er, die kennen den ja alle. Die Inder checken das sogar schon immer, so nach dem
Motto, kit bugger, kit bugger, kit bugger. Die kapieren das schon alle, die Inder. Der
braucht den Stimmverzerrer. Oh, ich sehe gerade, dass es hier Big Brain-Diskussionen
über Samarin und Cross-Plattform Kotlin-Java-Entwicklung gibt. Ah, jetzt exquisite Chat heute wieder.
Big Brain-Chat. Nerbeer ist auch am Start. So, falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, Leute,
im Chat, dann müsst ihr das noch mal schreiben mit Ed Wubblors. So, next. Mal gucken. Wir
sind in Europe-Berlin. Ja, wir sind ja 500 Kilometer weg oder so, aber das ist ja so
ungefähr. Ich will, nein, ich will no dead keys. Ist das das gleiche wie no dead keys?
Warum gibt es, das habe ich noch nie verstanden. Warum es so 50 Milliarden Abwandlungen von
Tastaturlayouts bedarf? Habe ich noch nie gecheckt, ehrlich. Noch nie. Und dann heißen
die teilweise noch anders. Ich nehme immer no dead key, weil, no dead key, dann kann
man hier den Kram hier ordentlich einfügen. Ja, die Location, klar, war die nur für Zeitzonen.
Da sind wir, Berlin. Next. Mach, mach, alles automatisch. Nein, Quatsch, wir brauchen
auch kein LVM hier. Install a bootloader, type hostname. Cute. Chat. Next. Warum kann
ich nicht installieren? Ah, hostname must be lowercase. Das war zu viel verlangt, dass
man too lower macht. Übrigens, Leute, kurze Unterbrechung für eine Runde C++ Rant. Vielleicht
habe ich das im Stream schon gemacht, aber ich muss mich öfters mal über C++ aufregen
im Stream. Wusstet ihr, dass C++ Standard Library oder STL, wie das da heißt, wusstet
ihr, dass es keine Möglichkeit gibt, einen Text in Großschreibweise, also einen String
to upper zu konvertieren, built in, in der Standard Library. Das kann jede noch so beschissene
Hobbyprogrammiersprache build in in der Standard Library. Jede. Mir fällt keine ein, die das
nicht kann. Aber in C++ geht es nicht. In C++ gibt es, es ist so hässlich. Ist nicht
performant genug, genau. Macht man nie, macht man nie. Das muss man lieber selbst programmieren,
das ist ja dann viel performanter. Guckt euch mal an, wie hässlich das in C++ ist. Hier,
hier. Hallo. Seid ihr noch ganz dicht? Die wollen ernsthaft, ernsthaft, ja. Also ich
weiß nicht, was mit dem C++ Gremium los ist. Die wollen ernsthaft, dass man String to upper
von Hand macht. Es ist keine built in Funktion dafür vorgesehen. Was ist mit den C++ Leuten
los? Warum gibt es sowas nicht? Ich mache jetzt jeden Stream 10 Minuten C++ Rant, weil
mir laufen Dinge auf. Ich habe mir sogar ein extra Textdokument gemacht, C++ Sackt und
dann schreibe ich alles rein, was mir in C++ auf den Sack geht. Das ist jetzt glaube ich
schon 80 Zeilen lang oder so. Weißt du, was mir letztens wieder aufgefallen ist? Es gibt
kein Standard Library String to upper. Es gibt so einen Crap hier wie Standard to upper
und angeblich, angeblich, mit C++ 20 gibt es dann irgendwas, was es einfacher macht
oder so. Aber ich weiß nicht, was mit den Jungs los ist. Ich kann es mir nicht erklären.
So, starten wir die Installation. Ah, yes, C++. Es ist wir, ehrlich. Username, aja ja,
real name, aja ja, aja ja. Passwort 123456. Ups, vertippt. 123456, 123456. Add. Admin,
natürlich Admin, was sonst? Als wo mal anderen Account als Admin. Ich glaube, es geht los.
Ähm, Englisch, German Keyboard, äh ja, Partitionier, User, System Details, alles klar, Install.
Yes. Warum probiert er so viele Diskos aus, ja um sich auszuprobieren? Der einzige Grund
um sie auszuprobieren. Ich habe ja schon mal eine Lieblings-Distro, die ich tagtäglich
auch auf der Arbeit verwende, aber ich will einfach mal gucken, was es sonst so gibt und
es ist eine schöne Sache für ein Stream zum Zeug ausprobieren. Ja, choose my name, time
Library C++ Standard Clip. Wer sich das ausgedacht hat, ey. Es hat eine gewisse Logik, muss man
sagen, aber es ist, es ist eklig. Es ist, es ist alles, es ist wirklich fast alles, was
ich mir an einfachen Aufgaben so überlegen kann, ist in C++ eklig zu machen. Da suchst
du, da suchst du auf Stack Overflow danach, weil du halt irgendwie feststellst, ok, so
einfach ist es nicht und dann schlägt dir einer vor, ach ist doch ganz easy, schreib
erstmal zwei Seiten Templates. So Sachen, wo ich mir denke, was, was wird euch los bei
C++? Sogar, und das heißt schon was, sogar in JavaScript ist das Daytime Handling einfacher
als in C++ und JavaScript Daytime Handling ist ein Sammelsurium aus alt, älter, mittel,
neu, neu und ganz neu. Wofür benutzt du eigentlich Distros? Wie? Du kannst Linux
ohne Distro eigentlich benutzen. Irgendjemand muss das für dich bauen oder du machst immer
vom Scratch, aber das macht wahrscheinlich kaum jemand von uns. Ero, drei Monate aktuell
im ersten fortlaufenden Monat, das ist HugeBrain von Twitch, dass es das anzeigt, im ersten
fortlaufenden Monat, das heißt im Endeffekt dann jetzt neu frisch abonniert, oder? Oder
heißt es erster fortlaufender Monat? Es ist der zweite Monat, wo du in Folge abonniert
hast. Das, wer weiß, fängt Twitch bei Null an, wie sich das gehört, oder bei Eins? Das
heißt erster Resub, oh Huge. Wahnsinn, Dankeschön für den Resub. Restart, oder schon fertig.
Fortitude, klingt wie ein Item aus Diablo. Fortitude Enchantment, eins, zwei, drei, vier,
fünf, sechs. So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal wieder einstellen, dass wir das Stretchen
ausmachen. Mal gucken, ob die so, hm, warum schafft es eigentlich keine Distribution
von Vmware Tools standardmäßig zu installieren. Warum? Das ist doch kacke. Ich verstehe nie,
warum so viele Leute sagen, was, das Linux ist besser? Man kann darin dasselbe machen,
Lull. Das Linux ist weder besser noch schlechter, genauso wie Mac OS oder Windows besser noch
schlechter ist. Man muss halt einfach gucken, was man für was verwendet. Wenn ich was spielen
will, verwende ich garantiert kein Linux. Wenn ich netzmak technisch was machen will,
oder rumbasteln will, verwende ich garantiert kein Windows. Und wenn ich irgendwelche Huge
IQ Grafikdesign machen will, dann verwende ich wahrscheinlich Mac. Es ist, eigentlich
ist dieser Betriebssystem vor, den die Leute da sich im Kopf zurecht zusammendichten, ist
kompletter Schwachsinn. Man nimmt einfach das, was für die Sache, die man machen will,
am besten ist. Na, unter Mac OS hast du beispielsweise das Problem, wenn du ähnliche Sachen müsst,
wenn du das verwenden willst, für Spiele kannst du auch vergessen. Aber viele Sachen
unter Mac OS sind einfach uralt und du musst das mal 3 Stunden nachinstallieren. Was Unix
Tools und Sachen angeht. So, ok, auf was basiert das denn überhaupt? Ok, wir brauchen erstmal
eine Konsole. Terminal. Wir müssen vor allem mal Tools nachinstallieren. Wie macht man
das? Abt? Jam? Wie installiert man hier? Was hat Solus? EOPK. Das ist ja wirklich mal
was eigenes zur Abwechslung. Open VM Tools. Open VM Tools. Install. Jawoll. Open VM Tools.
Gut. Und dann brauchen wir noch, ist das kaputt? Und dann brauchen wir noch, äh, Vm Mouse
und, guck mal, er ist ein Bug schon gefunden, man kommt nicht richtig zurück. Ah, ist alles
drauf. Ok, dann schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert oder ob wir erstmal rebooten
müssen. Hier, wahrscheinlich müssen wir erstmal rebooten. Oder Vm. Open. Vm. User. Hier, normalerweise
muss man das starten. Ok. Wir rebooten mal und gucken, ob es dann funktioniert. Und
dabei gucken, wie wir das machen. Solus Forever Tools. 3 Years ago. Open VM Tools. Warum Bing?
Weil es Default ist. Ich hab hier irgendwie, weil die noch gar nichts umgestellt. Mal gucken,
ob es jetzt funktioniert. Vielleicht geht es ja auch einfach. Ah, nee. Mist. Es geht
jetzt einfach. Ok, was muss man da jetzt alles starten dafür? So, erstmal root werden.
Einmal root werden, weil. Äh, start. Vm. Was? No. Yes. Ah, excellent. Easy. Geht. Enable.
Es laggt. Leute, es laggt. Huge lag. Seht ihr das? 5 FPS. 5 FPS. Was haben wir da? Ok,
was haben wir? 60 FPS haben wir angeblich. Das fühlt sich definitiv nicht an wie 60
FPS. Ist 3D Beschleunigung aktiviert. Ah, da haben wir schon ein Problem, woran es liegen
könnte. Machen wir mal aus und machen 3D Beschleunigung an. Mal gucken, ob es dann
besser funktioniert. Accelerate. Normalerweise verwende ich jetzt hauptsächlich DuckDuckGo
als Search Engine. Bin da eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit. Es war so schleichend. Ich
hab, ich hab komplett auf, also ich fand Google jetzt nie als Firma so geil. Aber ich
hab komplett auf Google geschwört, was, ähm, was die Suchmaschine angeht, ja. Äh, warum
geht das jetzt wieder nicht? Ah, es ist gleich viel weicher. Äh. Start. Äh. Geh. Warum
spackt das jetzt so rum? Warum, warum geht der Fullscreen jetzt nicht mehr? Was ist das?
Was ist da los? Hä? Komisches Ding. WTF. Da stand doch da, du musst die Tools ablenden.
Äh, ich glaube, da stand nur da. Guck mal, es ist viel weicher jetzt, viel weicher. Ich
glaub, der stand nur da, weil ich aus hatte. Okay, wenn das, wenn das rumspackt, ähm,
dann müssen wir das von Hand starten. Aber so, so auf Rebooten tun wir nicht. Okay, also,
was, was haben die hier? Das ist anscheinend ein komplett eigener, komplett eigener Desktop,
ohne, ohne, ohne, ohne, ohne, ohne. Oh, wow. Okay, fünf FPS. Wir sind back. Aber zumindest
das Terminal lässt sich einfacher, deutlich, äh, ruckelfreier verschieben. Gut, das liegt
jetzt aber an der VM. VM und 3D-Beschleunigung ist immer so ne Sache. An sich. Ob, ob, ich
Boah, das fährt, Alter!
Boah, das laggt.
Kann man hier irgendwie die 3D Effekte umschalten?
Effects...
Also das ist definitiv schon mal nicht in der Standard-Setting schon mal nicht für VM geeignet.
Das liegt er, das liegt eindeutig an der VM.
Eindeutig
Übrigens schon mal gut wir haben standard mission dark theme das das freut mich schon mal
Dark theme beste
Muss dark theme
Ja, der browser an sich fühlt das fühlt sich 4k fire place minus tech tips das ist immer ein gutes test video
Nicht 43k 4k fire place
Das ist ich gucke mir mal oder 8k ist das oder war das nicht sogar 8k 8k
Ah yes youtube werbung
Ok wir gucken jetzt wie sehr geht euch youtube auch so auf den keks mit diesem overlay
Also im normalen youtube kein problem im desktop da habe ich das geplogged aber die youtube ad die youtube app auf ios
Jedes mal jedes mal geht die mir auf den keks deswegen verwende ich fast bloß noch mein android tablet dafür jetzt
Weil mir das so auf dem keks geht und auf dem android tablet hat man halt passende youtube apps die
Kein nerf die kein problem sind dann
Ja serious max das geht aber nur wenn man jailbreak sort hat oder oder nicht
Ok stop wie kein hardtop drauf
Die auslastung ist tatsächlich für ein 4k video gar nicht ah moment
Jetzt 4k 4k sollte nämlich in der vm nicht laufen richtig
Macht es auch nicht
Das geht auch nicht also 4k in der vm da brauchste da brauchste einfach
GPU unterstützung und das funktioniert halt nicht richtig
Guck selbst 2k macht die drei cpu kerne sind die sind fast am limit
Funktioniert nicht da warte ich ja persönlich noch drauf bis es mal irgendeinen hersteller schafft von virtualisierungssoftware
Dass man den
Haust video decoder von der grafikkarte in der vm verwenden kann
Ja serious max super super genau das das kann ich kann ich nicht machen
Es ruckelt immer noch das kann ich nicht machen das ist ja ein handy von der firma
Der michael 50 billionen ist am start neuen jetzt erst aufgestanden
Ich würde gerne dieses ganze
Dieses ganze 3d zeug ausschalten aber das geht wahrscheinlich nicht
Okay
Dementsprechend ist
Zumindest solos solos budgie desktop mäßig ist für vm wäre nicht so gut geilen für vms
Was hat solos für den paket managern was eigenes was eigenes das basiert wohl
Nirgendwo drauf hier dass das da ist der paket manager
Das das da ist der paket manager
Als das überhaupt so funktioniert
Special special neuer package manager
Eo eo pk
Mal gucken mal in was das programmiert ist also wenn es binary ist kriegen wir das nicht raus
Aber es ist kein binary ist es ein pyson package manager
Ne dafür ist ein bisschen bisschen kurz
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es ein pyson programm
der package manager
Vermutlich war
Was ist denn der genaue sinn der installation von solos heute einfach angucken wir haben wir hier unsere
Linux bewertungs
Kriterien
Wenn ich die datei finde
C++
Ja
Wir haben hier unsere unsere linux bewertungs kriterien
Wo wir uns das ganze mal angucken also nun freundlichkeit installer also bis jetzt ist ziemlich ziemlich standard wir müssen vielleicht die
huge
Wir müssen vielleicht ein bisschen größere font im terminal machen
Ist das ein gnome terminal
Was ist das oder ist das was eigenes ja das ist ein gnome terminal
Es sieht es sieht wollte ich gar nicht sagen es sieht nämlich original aus wie ein gnome terminal so da stellen wir erst mal die schriftart um
Irgendwie in der lage wäre auszufinden wie man hier die schriftart umstellt
Leute wo ist die ah hier custom font heck
Oh
Das ist ein plus punkt meine lieblings schriftart ist vorinstalliert
Ich bin begeistert
Das ist ein plus punkt meine lieblings schriftart ist vorinstalliert ich bin begeistert
So muss es sein
So muss es sein sehr gut perfekt
Sehr gut das ist schon mal plus punkt bei mir
Mahatma gandhi ja dank schön für den sub und tschüss
Huge huge sub
Und jetzt müssen wir auch mal den hintergrund ausstellen gibt es jemand von euch meine frage ich weiß es ist geschmackssache benutzt ihr transparenten
terminal hintergrund ich mag es nicht
Ich mag es nicht so weil es ziemlich anstrengend ist drauf zu gucken so ist viel angenehmer drauf zu gucken
Also so finde ich viel angenehmer drauf zu gucken
als so
Ne ja nur ganz leicht also quasi so
Leicht blurr ok ich sehe es ist so ziemlich 50 50
Also ich mag terminal transparent mag ich nicht
Ich nicht meins
Okay, aber das gefällt mir voll zu den schon mal ganz gut
Wie aktuell das das ist jetzt wirklich eine spannende frage weil die besetzen nirgends wo drauf auf
bei bei solos jetzt müssen wir mal gucken wie aktuell die pakete sind wie durch sucht man hier was search
Und jetzt haben wir wie es code ist das dabei
Oh tatsächlich
Und wie lässt man sich jetzt die version anzeigen info vielleicht
Oh das ist das ist glaube sogar ziemlich aktuell
Schauen wir mal
Ich glaube das ist ziemlich aktuell
Ja, ziemlich aktuell aktuell ist
Ja, das ist gut kann man sich nicht beschwerden ist in ordnung
EOP warum warum EOPK
Warum EOPK
Solos ist die ist so kommt
Solos ist die ist so kommt EOPK
Insta
Alias abgleich EOPK warum EOPK kann man da überhaupt keinen Reim drauf machen okay wir gucken mal
Man EOPK solos package manager ah so
Wobei wo kommt das EO hier
Das EO könnte ich mir noch aus solos zusammen reiben
Aber warum E
Weiß man nicht genau
Richtige Boomer Mucke
Muss so sein extra packages package dependencies
Package dependencies
Okay, was installiert er hier standardmäßig noch dabei wenn ich wie es code installierte git okay
blip uv no gs ich glaube das braucht man ohne geht es nicht weil
weil elektronen elektronen gedünns
Perl Perl
Man vielleicht ist für den bild was ist
Ist ist solos eher so eine geschichte mit
fertigen paketen mit binaries drinne
Oder bildet der mir das jetzt irgendwie schauen wir mal
Okay, nein für ein eigenes bild wäre das ist das alles viel zu schnell der gefällt mir aber das gefällt mir
Das hat irgendwie was
Ist auch schön zu bedienen alles
Das gefällt mir gut bis jetzt
Lulve Kekwe
Schön
No, mpv okay, das ist media media player kann der kann der youtube zeug abspielen
An der youtube zeug abspielen
YouTube
Spielen
Oh, oh, der default media player kann kann kann youtube abspielen
Gar nicht schlecht kann der twitch abspielen
Okay, meine cpu leistung geht ein bisschen in die knie
Dadurch dass ich jetzt kann 8k video laufen ab kann man hier vielleicht die settings umstellen video track
eher
Das ist jetzt 8k 8k video track ist ein bisschen zu hart für den rechner hier
Mal ausmachen twitch twitch oblast kann der twitch abspielen standardmäßig das wäre nämlich das wäre richtig cool
Das wäre nämlich das wäre richtig cool
Open
Oh leute guckt mal hier
Wir können wir können uns selbst zugucken im media player
Das finde ich gut
Das das finde ich echt cool
Dass die stand das das ding standardmäßig twitch und youtube abspielen kann das gibt das gibt schon mal pluspunkte
Das gibt schon mal pluspunkte
Huge
Ist halt mpv ja ja das ist ich hab schon gesehen
Ja in der vm hat es leider keine hardware acceleration
Weil dann in der vm gibt es kein hardware decoder
Und ja ich muss maximal jahrelos recht geben es ist eine absolute zumutung dass auch unter linux
desktop also sprich
nicht in der vm so auf richtige hardware
Video playback im browser zum größten teil nicht hardware accelerated ist es ist einfach lächerlich im jahr 2000
Komplett kompletter witz
Ist i3 im package managet darin mit gaps du meinst hier
eher nicht
Ist ja ist ja in in manjaro und arch ist es ja auch nur user repo mit gaps wobei
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ist es nicht mittlerweile so doch es könnte sogar mittlerweile
in extras drin sein
Ja dhm videos kannst du knicken
dhm videos kannst du eh generell unter linux
Wobei ich glaube ganz ehrlich ich glaube amazon geht im chrome
Ja i3 die frage ist ob die drei gaps drinne ist
Gucken wir mal i3
Äh
Moin roffel 1436
Früher hat man doch roffel gesagt
Das ist komplett out heute sagt man keck w
Ähm
Oder keck w wie die
Sagen
Okay i3 ist dabei
Allerdings kein i3 mit
Oh hoho guck mal leute
Das ist sogar i3 gaps standardmäßig drinne
Big brain package maintainer wie es aussieht bei solos
Tanzer das hast du doch nur gefragt weil du genau wusstest dass es drinne ist oder gibst zu
Das ist ja schon mal gut dass es drinne ist
Mir gefällt es jetzt bis jetzt echt gut
Ascii aquarium oh ne das glaube ich nicht
Achso kann das über wildcard searches
Ich glaube das ist nicht drinne
Das ascii aquarium ist nicht drinne
Hast du dir mal den editor brackets angeschaut
Ja vor jahren mal
Weil ich dieses live html editing feature ganz cool fand
Aber das ist das ding nicht ziemlich tot mittlerweile
Hat selbst nicht adobe den kram
Wobei
Wie spricht man das eigentlich richtig aus leute
Jetzt mal real talk ja
Jetzt mal spaß bei seine
Heißt es adobe oder adobe
Sekunde
Aussprache adobe
Adobe
Slow
Alles klar
Ok
Adobe
Ok man spricht es mit i aus
Alles klar
Jetzt müssen wir bescheiden
Ich hab auf wie ich klein war
Babyhühnchen genau bei mir
Ich hab früher gesagt adob
Adobe
Oder adobe oder so hab ich früher gesagt
Danach hab ich festgestellt
Moment
Das ist ja ein englisches Wort
Dann hab ich gesagt adobe
Und irgendwann bin ich dann drauf gekommen
Es heißt adobe
Und nochmal eine Frage
Leute
Scsi
Scsi oder scasi
Eigentlich ist es komplett
Nicht mehr relevant
Heutzutage aber
Ich mein immerhin
Erlebt es weiter ja
Scsi
Scs
Das war's für heute.
Das war's für heute!
...
Move Workspace, Shift, Super, End.
Shift, Super, End.
Ah ja, hier sind wir jetzt, ok.
Und Shift, Super, Post, 1.
Auch eigentlich geht das sogar, ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Super Page, dann hab ich schon alles ausprobiert.
Das geht anscheinend nicht, weil meine Workspaces sind links und rechts.
Ah ja, geht, geht.
Die meisten Leute brauchen wahrscheinlich eh nur zwei.
Ich, ich brauch drei. Mindestens.
Also eigentlich hab ich sieben Stück, eigentlich hab ich sieben Workspaces.
Ich hab, also auf der Arbeit verwende ich auch alle sieben.
Ich hab's meistens so, ich hoffe, dass ich das Gericht aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege.
Also ich hab auf dem ersten Desktop hab ich Chrome immer auf.
Auf dem zweiten Desktop hab ich ein Terminal immer auf.
Auf dem fünften hab ich mein RDP auf irgend so eine komische Windows VM, die ich brauch.
Auf dem dritten hab ich meistens Programmierzeug auf.
Auf dem vierten hab ich Chat Messenger auf.
Auf dem siebten, das dürfen wir jetzt keinem verraten, Leute, Chat.
Psst, müsst ihr ruhig sein, Chat.
Also Achtung, auf dem siebten, auf dem siebten Desktop hab ich den Firefox mit Discord auf.
Und, und YouTube und Twitter, da guck ich ab und zu mal rein.
Und der sechste ist für irgendwie alle möglichen Sachen.
Ja, was meint ihr, warum ich auf der Arbeit so viel Twitter?
Also ich weiß nicht, so viel.
Ich tippe da gar nicht, ich setz da gegen ein, zwei Tweets am Tag ab, wenn irgendwas Interessantes passiert.
Das mach ich nicht vom Smartphone, ich mach einfach Twitter halt auf dem siebten Desktop auf.
Ist nicht verboten, ist erlaubt, muss man sagen.
Ich mach das jetzt nicht irgendwie Top Secret, sodass es keiner merkt, weil es verboten wäre.
Das ist erlaubt.
Aber ich hab's halt nicht ganz vorne.
Ich will jetzt nicht, dass das erste, was man sieht, ist bei mir wie mein Firefox mit Twitter auf oder so.
Nee, das hat bei uns auch kaum einer Probleme mit.
Ich mein, man macht ja trotzdem was.
Es ist ja eh komplett bescheuert, die Annahme.
Ich weiß, dass das in manchen Firmen so ist, aber die Annahme, dass Mitarbeiter in der Zeit,
wo sie mal kurz auf YouTube was gucken, oder auf Twitch was nachgucken,
oder sich auf Facebook ihre Messages lesen oder sonst was,
dass die halt dann quasi der vierte oder vierte oder vierte oder vierte,
die Messages lesen oder sonst was, dass die halt dann quasi der Firma Arbeitszeit stehlen würden.
Das ist ein kompletter Blödsinn.
In der Zwischenzeit, wo die das machen, würden die ja sonst nichts arbeiten.
Weil es ist, weil du einfach mal ab und zu fünf Minuten dich erholen musst
oder fünf Minuten dich mal ablenken musst, irgendwie ein bisschen was anderes machen.
Das ist vollkommen legitim und sorgt unterm Strich eigentlich nur dafür,
dass die Leute sogar mehr arbeiten, als wenn sie das nicht dürften.
Meine Ansicht bei der Sache.
NiceToastBro, Stufe 1, 5 Monate in Folge.
Huge Sub, Dankeschön.
Ist deine Aussage, dass YouTube-Videos mit 48 FPS eine viel höhere Bitrate haben,
noch valid, weil du letzten den 40 FPS hochgelassen hast?
Ja, bei 1080p ist das noch so.
Wenn ich Videos 720p mit 48 FPS hochgelassen habe,
ist das noch so.
Wenn ich Videos 720p oder 1080p hochlade,
dann würde ich die auf YouTube 30 besser achten,
also qualitativ mit 30 FPS sind sie besser.
Mit 48 sind sie halt deutlich flüssiger und besser als mit 40 FPS.
Weil 1080p und vor allem 720p hat bei YouTube halt eine absolut miese Bitrate.
Wenn man das macht wie ich in den letzten Videos und die in 1440p hochlädt,
dann kann man sie mit 60 FPS hochladen,
weil man dann genug Bandbreite bekommt bei YouTube.
Allerdings sehen sie natürlich trotzdem,
wenn sich jemand mit niedrigerer Bandbreite anguckt, kacke aus.
Deswegen kann ich euch auch nur empfehlen,
wenn ihr YouTube-Videos guckt und nur einen 1080p Bildschirm ab,
guckt die Videos trotzdem in 1440p an.
Was ist das denn für ein AYA-Terminal-Theme?
Keine Ahnung, das ist Default.
Das ist Default Solos Terminal-Theme.
Das sieht so aus.
So, okay, was wollt man als nächstes gucken?
Irgendwie dieser Optik-Look und Feel finde ich sehr gut bis jetzt.
Für VM ist es nicht gemacht.
Genauso wie Performance und Responsiveness
ich jetzt nicht fair beurteilen kann,
weil es ist halt eindeutig nicht dafür ausgelegt,
in der VM zu laufen mit das Brauch-3D-Beschleunigung,
die halt in der VM mehr schlecht als recht funktioniert.
Was für eine Schelche, das ist wahrscheinlich Basch.
Gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus, ja.
Mir fällt keine Distribution ein, die Default nicht Basch verwendet.
Fällt euch eine ein?
Basch ist einfach mittlerweile überall.
Ubuntu hat standardmäßig auch Basch.
Das Einzige, wo Ubuntu Dash verwendet ist,
ist wenn du Skripts ausführst, die explizit auf BinSH gehen.
Die interaktive Shell auf Ubuntu Server ist auch Basch.
Okay, ich kenne keine Distu... doch, doch, mir fällt eine ein.
Grimmel hat ZSH verwendet eine ganze Weile.
Grimmel Linux Live-CD.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Grimmel.
Okay, anscheinend.
Anscheinend gibt es das immer noch.
Grimmel.
Die haben ZSH als Default verwendet, als Live-CD,
aber ansonsten fällt mir nichts ein.
BinSH zeigt auf Dash, sag ich doch.
Junge, die Website ist richtig oldschool, ja.
Allerdings darf man das in dem Fall tatsächlich nicht nach der Website beurteilen.
Ich finde, es ist eine der besten Live-Distributionen, die es gibt.
Auch wenn die Website echt aussieht wie 2003.
Dafür kann man wahrscheinlich den Source Code...
Ja, das hat garantiert einer von Hand geschrieben.
Das sieht einfach so oldschool aus.
Okay, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Hier ist Code, ist halbwegs aktuell, haben wir ausgebildet.
Firefox und Chrome, stimmt.
Was haben wir da zu bieten?
EOPK.
Gibt es für Solos Custom Repos?
Würde mich mal interessieren.
Gibt es extra Third-Party-Packages?
Okay, mit Snaps wollen sie das jetzt machen.
Das heißt, die haben im Package Manager Snaps drinne.
Was Krimmel Ork ist bei euch gehostet?
Wie gesagt, das ist eine Live-Distribution, die kann ich nur empfehlen.
Von der Website darf man sich nicht abschrecken lassen.
Die ist ziemlich gut.
Snap, okay, was haben wir denn hier für einen Snap?
Durchsuchen wir mal, ob da schon Snaps drinne sind.
Third-Party, hier.
Android Studios dabei.
Oh Gott, Flash.
Geh mal fort, please.
Guck mal, ob es Sol gibt, das ist ein Fork von EOPK.
Moment, warum brauche ich für den offiziellen Paketmanager einen Fork?
Was denn das?
Gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Was haben die sonst noch hier?
Git Kraken?
Sieht aus wie ein Git Frontend.
Nur Noobs verwenden Git Frontends.
Kommandozeile einzig wahre, was Git Bedienung angeht.
Ernst gemeint jetzt.
Wenn ich unsere Java-Entwickler auf der Arbeit immer sehe,
wie sie in Eclipse und irgendwelchen anderen IDEs ihr Git Zeug zusammenklicken,
da ist es wirklich Pepega-Time angesagt.
Okay, wir können Chrome nachinstallieren.
Haben wir Chromium zu bieten?
FFmpeg Chromium?
Was?
Chromium's FFmpeg for Chromium-based browsers.
Moment, es ist Chromium's FFmpeg for Chromium.
What?
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Aber Chromium gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Aber Chromium gibt es zu installieren.
Checkboxen setzen statt 10 Dateifahler einzutippen.
Das ist schon Big Brain.
Ich weiß nicht, worauf dich beziehst.
WinClass 2.
Dankeschön.
4 Monate.
Huge Brain.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Auch gar kein Prime.
Richtig echter.
7 Monate schon.
Geht's aufwärts.
Huge.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs.
Bei Git weißt du, es geht GUI.
Achso, ja, da hast du recht.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie man Git mit einem GUI verwendet.
Das leuchtet mich überhaupt nicht ein.
GIT CLI, beste.
GIT CLI.
Git über die Kommandozeile hat ein paar merkwürdige Dinger drinnen.
Ja, manchmal ist die Frage, schreibt man Remote vorne hin mit einem Leerzeichen dazwischen.
Manchmal schreibt man das Remote dahinten mit einem Slash dazwischen.
Es ist nicht, also Git-Kommandozeilen-Bedienung ist auch nicht so komplett das Gelbe vom Ei.
Aber man kann damit wenigstens alles machen.
Und wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat, will man das nicht über den GUI verwenden.
Alle Leute, die Git über den GUI verwenden, sind nur zu faul gewesen bisher.
Da war ein bisschen die Kommandozeilenbefehle für zu lernen, einer Ansicht nach.
Und das Einzige, wofür wirklich ein Git-GUI ganz schön ist, wenn man den History-Craft will.
Weil das sieht in der Kommandozeile nicht so hoch aufgelöst aus.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich generiere mir zweimal im Jahr so einen History-Craft.
Das war's.
Braucht man eigentlich so gut wie nie.
Oh guck mal, wir haben sogar Jet-Brain-Zeugs drinnen.
Big-Brain, Jet-Brain.
Gibt sie Toolbox?
Gibt sie Jet-Brain-Toolbox?
Jet-Brainz.
Kotlin ist auch dabei.
Gibt sie Toolbox?
Das wäre natürlich huge.
Guck mal, man kann sogar Ryder und Ruby-Mine und Gedöns alles installieren.
Oh, das finde ich cool.
Das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir gut.
Dass so Sachen auch dabei sind.
Eine, das ist ein Snap, wollen wir mal gucken, ob das ein Snap ist.
Schauen wir mal, installieren wir mal Ryder.
Installieren wir mal.
So, Ruby-Mine, Skype-Gamer, Slack, Spotify.
Leute, wir haben auf der Arbeit jetzt seit letzter Woche Microsoft Teams am Start.
Slack ist ja zum Glück, der Kelch ist an uns vorübergegangen.
Dafür mussten wir uns die letzten zwei Jahre mit Skype oder die letzten drei Jahre mit Skype for Business rumschlagen.
Und ich kann euch sagen, Skype for Business ist mit Abstand der räudigste Messenger, den ihr je gesehen habt.
Skype for Business kann beispielsweise, das ist ein Messenger wohlgemerkt, kann beispielsweise keine Nachrichten an Leute schicken, die offline sind.
V.a. im normalen Messenger würde man ja erwarten, wenn man offline ist, bekommt man eine Message, geht online, dann kriegt man die Message.
Nicht so bei Skype for Business.
Das kriegt man dann als Mail zugestellt und in diesen Mail-Ordner, der irgendwie verpasste aufgezeichnete Unterhaltungen nennt.
So ein typischer Microsoft-Name, verpasste aufgezeichnete Unterhaltungen.
Da guckt nie jemand rein.
Auch Nachrichten, die länger sind als eine gewisse Zeilenanzahl, kann Skype for Business nicht.
Skype for Business ist absoluter Dreck.
Ich hab so viele Nachrichten nicht gesehen, weil mir jemand auf Skype for Business geschrieben hat.
Und ich hab Skype for Business eh schon ignoriert, weil ich hab das auf meiner Windows-VM auf der Arbeit laufen, da guck ich halt einfach nicht rein.
Und Teams ist relativ gut, muss ich sagen.
Also Teams ist ganz okay.
Teams ist ein bisschen so wie Skype für Arme.
Was laber ich? Wie Discord für Arme.
Also es kann halt viel weniger als Discord, aber dafür ist es halt Business.
Was installiert der da eigentlich? Fünf Stunden?
Okay, der macht da auch Sachen.
Der macht da Dinge im Hintergrund. Wir lassen ihn mal weiter machen.
Wir lassen ihn mal installieren.
Und Teams ist Slack für Arme. Ja, das kann schon sein.
Aber ich bin froh, dass Slack an uns vorüber gegangen ist.
Gar nicht mal, weil ich so extrem was gegen Slack habe.
Aber ich weiß, dass die ganzen Leute, die sich um Tool-Geschichten bei uns kümmern, die können nur Microsoft-Zeug und Atlassian-Zeug.
Das anderes können die nicht.
Deswegen ist es gut, dass sie Teams genommen haben. Das ist nämlich wenigstens was, was die auf die Reihe bekommen.
Was auch wieder ganz... Eine Sache, die mir bei Teams schon gleich auf den Keks gegangen ist, direkt nachdem...
Haben wir es heute noch mal hier?
Eine Sache, direkt nachdem es installiert wurde bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Also ein Riesenvorteil schon mal.
Es gibt eine Native Linux-Client für Teams. Das ist schon mal huge.
Wahrscheinlich ist es auch nur ein Elektron. Aber es gibt eine Native Linux-Client.
Es gibt eine Linux-Client im Browser halt in einem extra Fenster.
Eine Sache, die mir aber schon gleich auf den Keks gegangen ist, ist die sehr merkwürdige Ticket-System-Integration.
Ich wollte für unseren Channel unser Hiera linken.
Und das ging nur mit der Hiera Cloud-Version.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, wozu soll ich denn die Hiera Cloud-Version linken? Wir haben eine lokale Installation.
Der Pepega.
Ok, jetzt gehen wir mal auf Desktop 2 und starten mal Rider.
Es ist auch standardmäßig direkt gleich drinnen.
Man muss da nicht irgendwie was refreshen oder so. Das finde ich gut.
Teams kann keine halbwegs funktionieren Code Formatting Snippets.
Muss ich mal am Montag ausprobieren. Keine Settings importieren.
Confirm.
Now, wir senden nix.
Dark Theme, wunderbar. Visual Studio, ab, ab, ab.
Nein, haben wir doch schon.
Haben wir doch schon.
Environment, ja ist gut.
Natürlich blöd, ist nicht installiert.
Ah, gibt es.NET Core zum installieren?
Das probieren wir doch gleich mal aus. Gibt es.NET Core?
Search.
Was haben wir denn hier? Core.
Ach, was könnte ich da suchen? Ach, was könnte ich da suchen, da ich das finde?
Core Host oder so? Core SDK?
Immer eine glorreiche Idee..NET?
Search..NET.
Vielleicht ist es nicht dabei..NET Solus.
Ich glaube wir sind im Issue Tracker gelandet.
Okay, ist es jetzt da drin oder nicht?
Ah, Snap.
Man muss es wohl über Snap machen anscheinend.
Ups, falsch Desktop gewechselt, ist eigentlich auch nicht so wild.
Dann installieren wir das Ganze jetzt mal über Snap. Ist das drauf?
Snap. List. Snap. Install..NET.
Einfach nur so? Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken, Snap.
Was habe ich jetzt schon wieder leaked, Leute?
Ich leake hier laufend irgendwas.
Direkt gehackt. Fuck.
.NET Snap. Uhrzeit leaked. Oh shit.
MonkaS.
Okay, man kann einfach hier.NET SDK installieren.
Kann man nicht einfach Snap. Install..NET machen?
Okay, doch, stimmt auch.
Wie installiert man das? Hab ich noch nie gemacht. Snap. Install..NET.
Das brauchen wir nämlich für Rider, brauchen wir das.
.NET minus SDK.
Wie wäre es mal mit einer Kommandozeile, die ich ausführen kann?
.NET Core?
Wie installiere ich das? Install.
Ah, so.
Das ist ja auch kompliziert gemacht, oder?
Okay, man muss mal das schon mal als Route machen. Schon mal merkwürdig, warum muss ich das als Route machen?
Snap. Nipp, schnapp.
Von Kommandozeilen hält Microsoft nicht viel. Das kann man mittlerweile gar nicht mehr sagen.
Okay, das muss man wahrscheinlich nachher extra konfigurieren. Das kann man mittlerweile gar nicht mehr sagen. Ich beende das nochmal und guck mal.
Oh nee, geh weg.
Kannste ausgehen? Ich will nicht. Kill X.
Wie führt man hier Programme aus?
Execute irgendwas. Run? Gibt es was? Run?
Kill X. Nee, X kill. X kill.
Nee, ah fuck, geht nicht.
Das kann man mittlerweile gar nicht mehr sagen.
Warum kann ich hier kein Fenster X machen?
Das geht, das funktioniert, ja.
Aber trotzdem. Ups. Ah, wie der Desktop liegt, Leute.
Ha, wer sich gedacht hat, dass das funktioniert.
Warum kann ich kein Kill X machen? Na gut, dann nicht.
Evaluate for free.
Evaluate.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Continue.
Okay, jetzt konfigurieren wir mal.NET Settings.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Hier irgendwo war das drunter. Run Time.
Toolset ist übelst versteckt.
Hier, er hat es sogar erkannt.
Mono brauchen wir nicht. Guck mal, er hat es doch schon erkannt.
Snap, current.net, save, sehr gut.
Use solution.
Probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus, ob es prinzipiell funktioniert. Create.
Liegt.
Schauen wir mal, wie der liegt.
Ja, tatsächlich funktioniert alles dabei.
Ich bin begeistert.
Solos, das habt ihr gut gemacht.
Gucken, ob es runnt.
Geiler Satz.
Also Leute, wir schauen mal, ob es runnt jetzt. Hello World.
Das finde ich gut.
Find ich echt nicht schlecht bis jetzt. Gefällt mir, gefällt mir.
Also ich muss sagen.
Wir hatten ja bisher von allen.
Wie kommt man noch in die Settings? Keyboard Shortcuts.
Kann man Commandos runnen?
Also bisher von allen Desktop Distributionen, die wir bisher ausprobiert haben, muss ich sagen.
Das meiste war Crap.
Ganz gut gefallen hatten wir für totale Noobs.
Entry OS fand ich ganz gut.
Und Deep in Linux, wenn man damit klarkommt, dass es das China Linux ist, war auch ganz gut.
Für totale Noobs.
Solos, würde ich sagen, ist nicht unbedingt für totale Noobs.
Solos ist eher was für Entwickler vielleicht.
Für Leute, die ein bisschen Ahnung haben.
Aber trotzdem gerne was ordentlich vorkonfiguriertes haben wollen bis jetzt. Sieht es für mich so aus.
Was ich ganz gut finde.
So und wie kann man, gibt es hier einen Run Command?
Run.
Ah, Alt F2.
Habe ich doch gemacht.
Habe ich doch, habe ich doch gemacht.
Problem ist nur, ja gut.
Wir haben ja auch Sounds, habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Allerdings wirklich schön ist es nicht, oder?
So, ok, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Firefox, Chrome.
Ah, gibt es bei Chrome?
Bei Chrome gibt es nicht den Fork mit Videobeschleunigung anscheinend.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Das wäre natürlich richtig Premium, wenn es bei Chrome das gäbe mit Videobeschleunigung.
Das wäre natürlich richtig cool.
Aber gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Oder denke ich mal nicht, dass es das Chrome gibt mit Videobeschleunigung.
Nee, eher nicht.
Gibt es ihn eigentlich als Snap?
Das reicht, allerdings muss man das Snap auf jeden Fall extra konfigurieren, dass es Zugriff auf die Grafikkarte, Grafikencoderfunktion hat.
Security, Start Party.
Was hatten die sonst noch?
Npass.
Habe ich mal eine Weile verwendet, so einen Monat oder so, als Passwortmanager für unsichere Dinge, die ich einfach nicht plaintext hinschreiben wollte.
Denen, die sich damals so geziert haben, was ihr Security Audit angeht, habe ich den nie wieder verwendet danach.
Hast du dich mittlerweile mal mit ETFs beschäftigt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Meine Kohle liegt immer noch einfach so rum und das sackt.
Money Dance.
Hat der auch den Swag?
Ocean Audio, Fast Cross Platform Audio Editor, habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Ocean Audio.
Nee, wie hieß das Ding?
Ocean Audio, nicht Ocean.
Sieht aus wie 1995.
Installieren wir garantiert nicht.
Geplex ist für die ganzen Leute, die gerne hier Zeug gucken dabei.
Nicht schlecht.
Beim Text.
Weiber.
Gut, hält sich in Grenzen, was dabei ist.
Dafür kann man die ganzen Snap-Kram installieren, das ist doch okay.
So, also was testen, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Was haben wir?
Light IDE, Qt Creator.
Ja, das müssen wir tatsächlich auch gucken.
Das ist immer wichtig zu wissen, was für Entwicklerwerkzeuge dabei sind.
Weil, ich behaupte mal, dass einfach viele Leute die Linux nicht einfach so als Hobby Desktop Betriebssystem verwenden,
dass die eben entwickeln da drauf.
Und deswegen ist wichtig zu gucken, was 4.11.
Ich glaube, das ist halbwegs aktuell.
Das ist halbwegs aktuell.
Passt, das ist aktuell.
Qt Creator.
Install.
Following Dependencies.
Das ist egal, was ich hier anklicke.
Wahrscheinlich ist das alles install.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Welche Node.js Version ist dabei?
Gucken wir mal.
Hat er eben schon installiert?
Ach nee, da müssen wir machen.
Info.
12.141.
Ist das aktuell?
Ist LTS ja gut?
Es ist ja in Ordnung, dass man dann eine LTS Version vernimmt.
Wisst ihr, was ich übrigens mal ausprobieren möchte,
bei den nächsten Streams?
Wie heißt das?
Deno oder so?
GitHub Deno.
Das ist ein...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das wirklich Node.js Konkurrenz nennen kann.
Es ist von dem ursprünglichen Node.js Gründer,
einer der Mitgründer von Node.js,
eine neue JavaScript Runtime für den Desktop.
Allerdings Runtime muss man auch sagen.
Es ist V8 von Chrome.
Also Google V8 im Endeffekt drunter.
Allerdings ist TypeScript eingebaut
und noch ein paar andere coole Sachen.
Ich bin mir noch recht unschlüssig, wofür man das eigentlich braucht.
Aber 44.000 GitHub Sterne spricht für sich,
dass es nicht ganz so unsinnig sein kann.
Halbkorn, Mathe, welche Klasse oder studierst du?
Was ist gerade angesagt?
Mathe.
Ist doch mit Rust geschrieben?
Ja, teilweise.
Ja, ist es.
Okay, gehen wir mal hier auf den nächsten Desktop
und schauen wir mal, ob der Qt-Creator richtig funktioniert.
Projects, New Projects, Qt Widget Application.
Nee, wir machen keine Qt Widget Application.
Das sind aber doch die falschen.
Ist das die richtigen Vorlagen?
Choose, next, next.
Aktuelles Qt ist drauf, next, next, next, finish.
Jetzt aber ab was, don't show.
Okay, der Qt-Creator ist schon mal grausam vorkonfiguriert.
Ich meine, schwarz auf dunkel...
Das kann man nicht erkennen.
Ja, Halbkorn, viel Glück bei der Arbeit.
Und das Bild geht auch nicht.
Okay, das ist schon mal nicht gut.
Okay, das ist schon mal nicht gut vorkonfiguriert,
weil es geht nicht standardmäßig kaputt.
Aber wahrscheinlich lässt es sich relativ easy fixen.
Aber jetzt nicht, remove.
Die Frage ist jetzt, hat er auch alles jetzt removed, wenn ich es hier remove?
Das müssen wir mal nachgucken.
Qt, search.
Ha, wie sieht man, ob was installiert ist?
Info.
Sieht man, ob es hier installiert ist oder nicht?
Seht ihr irgendwo eine Anzeige, ob das Paket aktuell installiert ist oder nicht?
Wo sehe ich, ob das Paket installiert ist, was ich mir anzeigen lasse?
Mal gucken, ob der jetzt nämlich auch die Abhängigkeiten alle wieder aufgeräumt hat.
Nee, hat er nicht, hat er nicht.
Er hat den Kram draufgelassen.
Na gut, das ist natürlich nicht so schön.
Dann hat man ganz viel unsinnige Pakete nach und nach auf dem System drauf,
wenn man ein paar Sachen installiert hat und wieder runtergeworfen hat.
Das ist immer doof.
Das finde ich an Arch Linux echt ganz praktisch,
dass man die meisten Pakete ziemlich rückstandslos wieder los wird.
Dafür sind natürlich so Sachen wie Snap und Flatpak und Containergeschichten ganz gut.
Danach ist die Anwendung einfach weg.
Oh, die Peppers sind auch weg.
Mal neu.
Okay, dann gucken wir mal Default.
Okay, JetBrains Toolbox war nicht dabei, ist Light IDE dabei.
Komm, Scheiß drauf.
Go, Noobzeug, braucht keiner.
Genau, wir gucken mal, was für eine Go-Version drauf ist.
Das ist auch ganz interessant.
EOPK, Search, Search, jetzt ist die Frage, Go oder Golang?
Info, welche Version?
1137, ich habe keine Ahnung, legit kein Plan, was gerade für eine Go-Version aktuell ist.
Die hier, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Also Go ist die allerneueste Version drin.
Was ich noch nicht so hundertprozentig gecheckt habe, ist Solos Rolling Release.
Ist das Rolling oder ist das so ein Zwischending?
Zwischen manchen Sachen Rolling.
Ach hier, okay, ist das Rolling Release.
Curated Rolling?
Ah, okay.
Dann ist es so ein halbes, sprich, es ist nicht automatisch, auf Teufel komm raus, bleeding edge.
Man muss aber nicht neu installieren, im Endeffekt keine Upgrades machen, man kriegt immer neue Versionen.
Allerdings, es wird sich angeguckt, bevor es eine neue Version gibt.
Warum tust du dir denn Solos an? Ich finde es bis jetzt nicht schlecht.
Also ich muss sagen, von den Sachen, die wir bisher ausprobiert haben, ist das von dem, wie sich das für mich jetzt so darstellt, eines der besten, die wir ausprobiert haben bisher.
Version 1.3.30, oh, das ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Version, da fehlt noch was.
Ob die schnell bei Sicherheitspatches sind? Oh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Gab es letztens wieder eine Sudo-Geschichte? Und die letzte Sudo-Geschichte ist ein halbes Jahr, Alter, nicht, wie ich mich erinnern kann.
Was ist die richtige Sudo?
Jetzt aktuell, ok. Vom 31.01. ist das.
Die Sudo-Version 1.8.1 abgesichert. Ok, die haben die neueste. Passt.
Die haben 1.8.3.1, also da sind sie zumindest sicherheitstechnisch ganz, ganz gut dabei.
Ach, ja, ich sehe es gerade wieder, dass es jetzt auch anscheinend was bei Sudo gab.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt. Die letzte Sudo-Sicherheitslücke, an die ich mich erinnern kann, die ist irgendwie ein halbes Jahr oder so her.
Das war die, wo du an Sudo... Was war das nochmal? Was musste man hinten dranhängen?
Man musste einfach nur was hinten dranhängen und hatte Rudrechte, das war total für'n Arsch.
Haben wir, glaube ich, sogar im Stream ausprobiert.
Die Raute? Ich weiß es nicht, bei was die Raute... Wir haben es im Stream ausprobiert und es hat funktioniert.
Es war total Eats. Eats AF war das, da Rudrechte zu bekommen.
Also das ist alles halbwegs aktuell. Was gucken wir nochmal?
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was für eine Ruby-Version draus. Ich bin immer noch alter Ruby-Fan.
Auch wenn ich in letzter Zeit wenig Grund habe, was mit Ruby zu machen.
Ruby?
Wo? Ah, hier.
Ach, man muss Info machen, da muss ich mich immer noch dran gewöhnen. Info.
265, ich glaube, das ist ziemlich aktuell.
No.js haben wir geguckt,.NET Core war nicht drin, nur als Snap. Was für eine Docker-Version dabei ist? Das ist eine interessante Frage.
Wir gucken erstmal, was für eine Python-Version dabei ist.
27? What? 27? Heißt das vielleicht Python 3? Ah, ja.
369? Leute, 369 Python ist das halbwegs aktuell, ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, das ist halbwegs aktuell. Copy-Paste geht irgendwie nicht.
Docker? Was haben wir für eine Docker-Version dabei?
Die ist, ich glaube, auch ganz okay. Ist das nicht sogar die aktuelle?
Die versteckt, Docker versteckt ihre Versionen immer so. Brauche ich immer eine Weile, die zu finden.
19.03.5? Ja, ist die aktuelle.
So, dann installieren wir mal eine Runde Docker Compose.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir einen Docker-Container oder so starten können.
Als Abhängigkeit installiert Docker Compose auch Docker mit, so wie das sein sollte.
Docker-Compose-Who-Am-I-Example.
Probieren einfach mal den Billig, äh, den Noob-Test aus, ja.
Einfach diesen Who-Am-I-Container starten.
Einen Traffic starten wir nicht, wir wollen einfach nur den ausstarten.
Compose. Oh!
Das ist illegal, Leute. Kein Wim dabei.
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Anzeigeabmahnung, äh...
SWAT ist raus. Das geht nicht.
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Das sollte echt verboten sein.
Oh, wir haben sogar Neo-Wim zu bieten.
Wir haben sogar Neo-Wim zu bieten, okay.
Da ist die Entwicklung auch ein bisschen eingeschlafen, ein paar Neo-Wim.
Haben wir denn auch einen grafischen?
Haben wir denn Wim-GTK oder sowas?
Install Wim.
Ja, sudo.
Übrigens, Leute, ich habe euch schon 50.000 Mal diesen Trick gezeigt,
mit sudo ausrufezeichen aufrufezeichen.
Aber ich verwende ihn selbst kaum.
Kaum geht es um Text-Editors, geht... ist alle, alle wieder.
So, haben wir das compiled? Ja.
Okay, allwegs ordentliche Default-Settings.
Standard-Farbschema und so. Passt, kann sich sehen lassen.
So.
Der sollte jetzt in... äh, ab. Der sollte jetzt in... oh, Docker ist nicht gestartet.
Warum nicht? Weil kein Bock.
So.
Docker. PS. Nee, läuft nicht.
Okay. Ähm, oh fuck, was muss man da jetzt mittlerweile starten?
Probieren wir mal aus, start. Ist es Container-D, Docker? Nee, einfach nur Docker.
Oder Container? Nee, Docker.
Docker. Was haben wir denn zu ausfallen? Socket-Service. Start.
Okay, darf ich jetzt? Get Permissions. Aha.
Darf man als Root? Als Root darf man.
Das ist eigentlich okay. Ähm, dann machen wir das jetzt einfach mal als Root.
Um zu gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Äh, wo hab ich das denn jetzt angelegt?
Äh, in welchem Verzeichnis hab ich das jetzt angelegt?
Hier, doch.
Home, ayaya. Da sind wir doch richtig.
Home, ayaya.
Docker.
Docker. Compose. Ab.
Ja, funktioniert. Zwar als Root. Zwar so, wie man es nicht machen sollte.
Du musst dein... Jaja, ich weiß, dass man das machen muss.
Aber ich will jetzt nicht. Ich will einfach noch gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Starting on port 80. Localhost 80.
Okay.
Ach so, geht ja nicht. Ich hab ja keinen Port exposed. Geht nicht.
Logisch. Kann nicht funktionieren.
Ähm, dann...
Ähm, brauchen wir mal...
Haben wir denn TMAX zu bieten?
Welche Version haben wir da von?
Was haben wir da für eine Version?
Ah, Gott. Warum...
Warum hat jedes Kommando eine andere Option, um rauszufinden, was man für eine Version hat?
TMAX Version. Was haben wir da zu bieten?
3.dings alpha
Was ist die letzte...
TMAX Version?
2.9.
Okay, die ist schon ein bisschen älter, die dabei ist.
Die ist ein bisschen älter.
Aber kann man mit leben?
Vor allem der Q-Chat ist am Start.
Ja, das ist genau das gleiche. Recursive minus Kleiner minus Großer.
Die können sich alle nicht entscheiden. Bei SCP ist es minus Kleiner.
Bei User-Berechtigung ist es Großer.
Bei Grab ist es, glaube ich, Grauch Großer für Recursive.
Feind hat erst gar keine Option. Das macht standardmäßig Recursive.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen Wildwuchs, was Linux-Kommando-Zeilen-Tools angeht.
Es sind doch nur drei. Unix-like, BSD-like oder GNU-like.
Ja, dann sag mir mal, was Java verwendet jetzt.
Ich glaube, ich habe schon alle Kombinationen gesehen, die es irgendwie gibt.
Ich kenne minus Version, minus V, minus Version.
Manche sind ganz abgedreht, die machen nur Version.
Voll für den Arsch.
Java, ja.
Wo ist eigentlich mein Kaffee?
Java-People-Kaffee.
Da hatten wir heute noch gar nicht.
Aber bis jetzt gefällt mir das eigentlich ganz gut. Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Gut, das brauchen wir nicht. GIT. Welche GIT-Version?
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch. Version.
Ich glaube, GIT kann man auch so machen. Das ist mein...
What the fuck? Warum?
GIT meint, geht minus V auch? Nein.
Minus Version? Mal gucken, wir gucken jetzt auf, wie viele Varianten das funktioniert.
Ne, anscheinend nicht. Anscheinend geht nur Version und Version. Minus, minus Version, Version.
225. Ich habe aus dem Kopf keine Ahnung, welche GIT-Version aktuell ist.
Weil ich habe bei mir auf der Arbeit einfach immer die aktuelle GIT-Version drauf.
Ich gucke da nie nach. Ich weiß, es ist die aktuelle.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist die auch halbwegs aktuell.
2.25, sogar vor ein paar Tagen erst released.
Und da sind wir schon am Start. Das mag ich, das gefällt mir.
Also da muss man sagen, paketmäßig und so, echt alles in Ordnung.
So, NPM und Geschiss ist natürlich auch drauf, weil...
Ist Dings hier, die NPM-Konkurrenz im Paketmanager, müssen wir mal schauen.
Ah, tatsächlich, guck mal.
Warum kann mich das Ding eigentlich nicht nach einem Root-Passwort fragen?
Und ich muss jedes Mal ein Sudo davor machen? Das ist ein bisschen doof.
Fände ich schöner, wenn mich das Ding einfach fragen könnte nach einem Passwort.
Ok, dann install Vue CLI.
Gucken wir mal, ob der Kram alles problemlos funktioniert.
Weil ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, dass viele Leute den Kram eben halt als Entwicklerechner verwenden.
Brauchen wir das wirklich global?
Solange global im Heimatverzeichnis bleibt das alles gut.
Das ist so geil, ne? Du installierst JavaScript-Dinger und er lädt das halbe Internet runter.
Man kann den JavaScript nicht mehr installieren ohne Deprecated Warning.
Guck dir das mal an.
Das ist auch out of date, alles out of date.
Ja, das ist lightweight.
Es ist nur das halbe und wenn man die Java-Micro-Installation, dann ist es wahrscheinlich sogar nur das Viertel-Internet.
Aber was der hier alles runterlädt, ist der Wahnsinn.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal? Vue New?
Ah, ich hab's nicht im Path, kann das sein?
Was muss man da in Path packen?
Macht das so selten? Was muss man bei Jan in Path packen oder muss man einfach sich mal einloggen und wieder einen ausloggen?
Ne, oh Gott.
Was muss man da in Path reinpacken, dass es funktioniert?
What?
Ne, es ist eigentlich nur noch Vue mittlerweile.
Das liegt hier irgendwo drinnen, guck da.
Da liegt's. Also das da muss ich in Path packen.
Aber gibt's nicht noch Optionen, dass er das für mich macht irgendwo?
Ach hier, guck mal.
Ah, das ist gut.
Sehr schön, das machen wir.
Einloggen, ausloggen und...
Ah jetzt. Und jetzt geht's.
What? Warum?
Hä? Wait.
Moment, warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Ich hab das in meine Bash AC eingetragen, das muss eigentlich funktionieren.
Ne, ich muss meine Bash AC nicht sourcen, ich hab mich ausgeloggt und eingeloggt.
Wenn ich mich aus und eingeloggt hab, jetzt geht's.
Da macht der nächste in die Bash AC automatisch mit ein.
Oder hab ich mich nicht aus und eingeloggt? Doch, ich hab mich aus und eingeloggt.
Aber jetzt funktioniert's.
Was geht das, Vue new und dann hier irgendwie Client App oder sowas?
Ach Gott, die Option, add, ne, create, create, ist das.
Create, genau.
Ah, so select features, wir wollen den ganzen Mist noch mal nicht haben.
Mal eben kein Linter, wer braucht schon Linter?
Komplett overrated. Bash ist nicht T-Max.
Naja, aber T-Max startet Bash, das heißt wenn ich T-Max zumache und T-Max neu starte,
dann startet er auch ne Bash neu.
Brauchen wir alles net, alles, alles weg.
No. Yes.
So, jetzt installieren wir noch mal das halbe Internet mit, weil wir ein neues Projekt anlegen.
Ich mein, wir installieren nur ungefähr 14.000 Pakete für ne einfache Webseite.
Nur, also, ne, das ist ganz...
Oh, guck mal Leute, Emoji Support in der Shell, defaultmäßig schon drinnen.
Ich muss echt sagen, so für ne out of the box Developer Kiste macht mir Solus keine schlechten Eindruck.
Der eine, du weißt schon. Moin.
Interessant.
Find ich gut.
Warum Emojis? Weil nice, ja.
POC Red Tiger, zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Huge Stub.
Das find ich gut.
So, also, gehen wir mal rein und gucken ob unsere Webseite funktioniert.
Jawoll. Open Link, da isse.
Klappt.
Doch, ich find Emoji Support im Terminal standardmäßig schon nicht verkehrt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie kompliziert es mittlerweile ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, vor so ungefähr zwei Jahre oder so,
wo ich mich mal hingesetzt hab und mein Manjaro komplett neu gemacht hab,
war es echt ne Wissenschaft für sich,
da die richtige Kombination aus nem aktuellen Terminal, nem aktuellen Font-Config,
ne Emoji Schriftart mit dem richtigen Emoji Format,
weil es gibt ja Leute, das ist absolutes Minenfeld Schriftarten und vor allem Unicode Geschichten.
Es gibt glaube ich drei oder vier verschiedene Standards für Schriftarten,
wie man Color Emojis speichern kann.
Es gibt die Adobe Geschichte, es gibt die Microsoft Geschichte,
es gibt die Apple Geschichte und ich glaub die Android Chrome Geschichte.
Es gibt vier verschiedene Varianten, wie man Color Emojis in ner Schriftart encoden speichern kann.
Und es ist so unglaublich beknackt eigentlich, wenn man sich mal überlegt, ja,
dass da jeder wieder sein eigenes Süppchen baut und wenn man sich mal überlegt,
was eigentlich alles dahinter steckt, dass hier so ne Emoji überhaupt funktioniert
oder generell das Unicode Zeichen überhaupt ordentlich funktionieren.
Na ok, die Fonts sind zumindest die gleichen.
Sind die Fonts die gleichen?
Nein, guck mal, Leute, seht ihr es?
Firefox benutzt seine eigenen Emojis.
Hier sieht man schon mal schön den Unterschied, sogar auf der gleichen Plattform sehen Emojis unterschiedlich aus.
Und das liegt in dem Fall, weil Firefox eine eingebaute Emoji Schriftart mit eingebauten Font-Renderer für Emojis verwendet
und das Terminal eben eine andere Emoji Schriftart mit einem anderen Format wie Emojis gespeichert werden
und irgendeine Mischung aus GTK, Font-Config und Pango für Fonts.
Das ist echt Big Brain, wer das verstanden hat, der kann auch alles andere.
Der Hype-Train ist bei 94% Leute, der Scam-Train läuft.
Auf, auf Leute, go, go.
Ihr kriegt, was kriegt ihr denn dafür?
Ihr kriegt von Twitch, glaube ich, irgendwelche Emojis, wenn der Hype-Train traint.
Gehst du auf die GPN? Nein, mache ich nicht.
Amazon Prime gekündigt und kostenfrei abonniert?
Ja, dankeschön für das Abo, aber dann kannst du wahrscheinlich nicht lange abonnieren, wenn du Amazon Prime gekündigt hast.
Hi Happen, 9-11 oder doch lieber 9-1-1.
5 Monate, dankeschön.
Monka Smoke.
Nice.
Ja, ich könnte jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter rumrenten über Font-Render-Geschichten, aber diese ganze,
diese ganze Mischmasch aus Unicode, Standards, verschiedene Encodings, Font-Renderer, Schriftarten und so,
das ist wirklich eine Wissenschaft für sich, das ist echt kompliziert.
Für viele Leute ist der UTF-8 gleich Unicode, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Unicode legt ja einfach nur fest, ganz grob gesagt, was es für verschiedene Zeichen gibt, mit welchen Codes.
UTF-8 ist das eigentlich Encoding.
Unicode, auch wenn es sich wie ein Encoding anhört, ist kein Encoding, so wirklich.
Komm, Font-Geschichten, lass mal einfach mal weg.
Ja, und für Unicode verbreitet sind ja schonmal vorneweg drei Sachen.
Das UTF-8, das ist so das neueste.
Das Schöne an UTF-8 ist, ich rente jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen über Font-Geschichten und Emojis,
dass das Gute an UTF-8 ist, dass es abwärtskompatibel zu ASCII ist, für die ersten 256 Zeichen.
Danach ist UTF-8 ein sehr merkwürdiges Encoding, weil es, kann es eigentlich als Mischmiss erzählen,
ich bin mir aus dem Kopf nicht mehr ganz sicher.
UTF-8 verwendet über 256, also über einem Byte verwendet das das letzte halbe Byte,
um zu signalisieren, ob danach noch ein weiteres Byte kommt für Multi-Byte-Zeichen.
Das ist total wirr.
Das heißt UTF-8 ist auch nicht unerhebliche Rechenaufwand dahinter, um zu checken.
Und Emojis sind glaube ich fast alle vier Bytes.
Voll für den Arsch. Egal, ich fange davon jetzt gar nicht an.
Bei UTF-16 kannst du dir den Kram auch nur zum Teil spannen.
Ich finde UTF-16 ist das Schlechte aus beiden Welten.
UTF-16 ist das Schlechte aus beiden Welten.
Es ist zwei Byte, es ist nicht kompatibel zu altem ASCII Zeug
und vier Byte-Zeichen passen trotzdem nicht rein und du brauchst den ganzen Kram wie bei UTF-8.
Also entweder UTF-8 oder 32.
Java und.NET haben glaube ich UTF-8 intern.
Einfach keine Emojis, so sieht es aus.
Was ich jetzt noch schnell ausprobieren wollte, wie das mit Emojis aussieht, wenn ich Chrome installiere.
Ja, das Andetleet kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Das ist ja nochmal eine Emoji Eigenart, dass die Kombination von zwei verschiedenen Sachen was anderes ergeben.
Also dass man dann beispielsweise, ja wie du gesagt hast, dunkelhäutige Daumen hoch oder so machen kann.
Command Bra.
Chrome wollte ich installieren.
Und dann mal gucken wie da hier die Seite aussieht.
Und dann sehen wir schon, es sieht halt überall anders aus.
Mal hier so zum Vergleich.
So sieht es im Terminal aus.
Was ist das? Emoji One?
Was meint ihr, was ist das für ein Fond?
Ist das Emoji? Könnte sein, ich weiß nicht.
Könnte Emoji One sein.
Noto Sans.
Okay, ja.
Hast du eigentlich mal Angular ausprobiert?
Ja, vor Jahren.
Vor Jahren, als es noch Angular 1 war oder fast sogar noch Testversion.
Danach nie wieder.
Und die neuen Versionen haben mich auch extrem abgeschreckt.
Weil ich das gefühlt habe, kleine, kleine Projekte, für kleine Projekte ist Angular nichts.
Das ist ja, zumindest das was ich mir angeguckt habe, kommt das Spoilerplate technisch ja schon an fast eine Java Anwendung dran.
Okay, also jetzt starten wir mal Chrome und machen das da zum Vergleich nochmal auf.
Ja, nervt mich.
Guckt, und Chrome ist schon mal komplett kaputt und verwendet als Fallback die alten, auch noch die alten Android Emojis, nicht mal die neuen Android Emojis.
Also man sieht drei Anwendungen, drei unterschiedliche Emojis und komplett kaputt eigentlich.
Das ist so lächerlich, dass das so kompliziert ist.
Nein, die hier gefallen mir am besten.
Ich glaube, das sind auch die, die Twitter hat. Sind das nicht die Twitter? Sind das nicht die Twitter Emojis, die die Firefox standardmäßig verwendet?
Wartet mal kurz.
Warte, ich muss mal kurz rüber, der Fernseher geht nicht.
So, MaxTechnikSupport hat das ganze fachmännisch gefixt, Fernseher geht wieder.
Das Problem war, dass der Unity Media Router, diese komische Unity Media Speed, Speed, nee, nicht Speed Pod, Speed Pod Telekom, wie heißt das Ding? Connect Box, dass die da Meinung ist, wenn die Verbindung zu Unity Media abricht, alle Requests auf eine Fehlerseite umleiten zu müssen, auf der steht, Unity Media geht nicht.
Und damit kommt das Shield TV nicht richtig klar, weil das Shield TV dann eine Webseite aufmacht, weil es denkt, ich bin hinter einem Access Point, der eine Webseite mit Anmeldungen verteilen möchte.
Und da geht beim Shield TV immer der Browser auf, wo dann die Unity Media Seite angezeigt wird, Unity Media hat keine Verbindung. Was total fail ist, ja, und das verwirrt natürlich die Leute dann immer, weil dann auf einmal eine große Fehlermeldung drauf steht.
Ich hab schon fünfmal gesagt, so nachdem man drückt, einfach weg, geh einfach ins Hauptmenü, mach Kodi an und gut ist. Aber das ist richtig fail.
Ich hab mir schon überlegt, ob ich das nicht irgendwie blocken kann, aber mir ist noch nichts gescheines eingefallen, wie ich das blocken könnte, weil das ist ja was, das macht die Unity Media Connect Box quasi bei einem normalen Request, wenn der ins Internet gehen sollte.
Das kann ich nicht blocken, weil das ist ja ein legitimer Request und ich weiß ja auf dem Router davor nicht, ob Unity Media down ist. Boomer macht das Angst, ja ohne Scheiß, ist echt so.
Was du für einen Fernseher hast du denn? Oh, irgendein Sony, 5,5 Zoll. Ich hab doch ein Video darüber mal gemacht. Ich sag mal, was ich für einen Fernseher hab.
Wie ist das nicht Wohnzimmer, irgendwas mit einem Wohnzimmer? Hier, den da, den hab ich hier mit einem Shield TV. Hier das Teil.
Was kostet der eigentlich mittlerweile? Ah, ist deutlich günstiger geworden. Als er neu war hab ich um die 2000 Euro noch für bezahlt. Jetzt natürlich billiger ist jetzt auch nicht mehr das ganz neueste Modell.
Das klingt gut. Kommt das Google Chrome Tipps Video? Ja, kommt noch. Guckst du dir eigentlich die neue Overwatch Season an? Nein.
Und wisst ihr warum ich mir die neue Overwatch Season nicht angucke Leute? Leute, ich geh mal davon aus, Leute die es verfolgt haben wissen warum. Ratet mal warum ich mir die neue Overwatch League Season nicht angucken werde.
YouTube, genau, SaitoTV. YouTube. Oi. Oi. YouTube, Alter.
Warum macht man sowas auf YouTube Gaming? Man hat es bei Hearthstone gesehen. Hearthstone Viewerzahlen für die letzten Turniere im Boden versunken.
Handelt Unity Media Box deine DNS Anfragen? Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher wie ich meinen Router konfiguriert habe.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Also das hier ist mein Router. Was? Achso, es ist natt. Deswegen seh ich das hier gar nicht.
Also ich verwende intern für DNS meinen Router. Allerdings der Router was der als Uplink DNS verwendet. Ich glaube ich hab den Google DNS oder Cloudflare DNS eingestellt. Aber ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher. Es könnte sein das der tatsächlich die Connect Box verwendet.
Das kann sein. Aber echt läuft Overwatch League auf YouTube? Da muss ich mal gucken was Chat und Zuschauer sagen.
Hier, Live. Naja geht doch. Die Zahlen sind gar nicht schlecht. Die Zahlen sind ungefähr so hoch wie auf Twitch. Ein bisschen niedriger wie auf Twitch. 9.8.000 ist doch ok.
Hätte schlimmer sein können. Hätte schlimmer sein können. Oh Leute ich muss mal kurz ab. Ich muss mal kurz ab ich bin gleich wieder da.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.